mon tipi c'est la quatrième crèche
inter-entreprise de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ouvert depuis
le 2 janvier la crèche du groupe people
and baby peut accueillir 31 enfants
âgé de trois mois à 4 ans les enfants
sont séparés en deux sections petit
moyen et moyen grand Fanny la maman de
Maceo 4 ans est enthousiaste il est
beaucoup plus épanoui on sent qu'il a
envie de venir
il fait des choses il a des activités
qui lui sont proposées et c'est ce qui
lui mangeait en fait chez la nourrice
déjà l'environnement ils arrivent c'est
pas une télé un canapé c'est des jeux
c'est un environnement adapté pour eux
des tables à leur hauteur et puis après
voilà il y a des activités ils font des
chapeaux pour mardi gras voilà on leur
propose du dessin de la peinture c'est
c'est vraiment adapté pour eux
mon tipi à Montigny-le-Bretonneux est
uniquement accessible aux parents
salariés de la Banque Populaire Val de
France et du groupe Bouygues
Construction avec des horaires flexibles
8 heures 19 heures la crèche souhaite
offrir des services supérieurs au crèche
municipal
l'architecture de la crèche c'est très
bien pensé on a un matériel
pédagogique
on est énormément gâté et on a des
professionnels diplômés ce qui n'est pas
le cas dans toutes les structures dans
toutes les crèches vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'habiter la commune pour avoir
une place votre seul contrainte à vous
finalement c'est que soit le papa soit
la maman fasse partie de partie d'une
entreprise qui réserve des places et
vous êtes sûr d'avoir votre place de du
tout petit âge du bébé jusqu'à ce qu'ils
partent à l'école et ça c'est super
parce que bon bah voilà c'est c'est ça
ça rentrait serein et l'enfant et le
parent bien sûr
pour les parents le tarif est le même
que pour les crèches municipales il
varie de 87 centimes d'euros à 2 euros
83 par heure selon les revenus et le
barème fixé par la Caisse d'Allocations
Familiales couches soin et alimentation
bio tout est fourni l'entreprise
adhérente elle cotise à la hauteur du
nombre de places réservées
il y en a du monde